تنضم الينا من روما وزيره خارجيه جمهوريه
سلوفينيا تانيا مرحبا بك سيده ثانيه فاين
سنبدا معك من موقف سلوفينيا من الاتفاق
الذي يوشك ان يتم الانتهاء منه بين
الحكومات الاوروبيه
لوضعي سقفا على اسعار النفط الروسي ما هو
موقفكم من هذا الامر
من اجل التعامل مع ارتفاع الاسعار الذي
يحدث وبالتالي من المهم بالنسبه
الطاقه الروسيه لذلك نحن نسعى ليكون هناك
تنويع للموارد على المستوى القصير والطويل
حتى يكون هناك استثمارات بالنسبه
لاسعار خصوصا عندما يتعلق الامر بوضعي سقف
يتصدى لارتفاع الاسعار
ولكن نحن نسال عن موضوع ال التعامل مع
النفط الروسي تحديدا اليوم هناك توجه
اوروبي لوضع سقفا لاسعار النفط المنقول
بحرا من روسيا على 60 دولارا للبرميل
وهمم هناك كان خلاف في داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي حول السقف الذي يجب وضعه انتم في
سلوفينيا ما هو موقفكم من هذا الامر كيف
تتعاملون معه
في سلوفينيا كما تعلمون نحن نعتمد بشكل
كبير جدا على النفطي وغازي روسيا لكن ليس
بامكاننا ان ننسى مسؤليه الاعتداء التي
تجري وكذلك
الحرب التي تجري في اوكرانيا تدمير البناء
التحتيه الخاصه بالطاقه والمياه التي تجبر
الاشخاص على الهروب لذلك نحن نسعى لوجود
بدائل نحاول ان ننوع مواردنا الخاصه
بالطاقه ولقد قمنا بامضاء عقد مع الجزائر
للسنوات القادمه وبدا من يناير القادم
سنحصل على الغاز مرورا بتونس وايطاليا
وصولا الى السوفليه هذا مصدر مهم بالنسبه
لتوريد الذي يصل لنا وخصوصا بالنسبه
للطاقه الكهربائيه والموارد الاخرى في
الشتاء القادم نحن في امان لكن على الماده
البعيد لابد نستثمر في الطاقات المتجدده
الذين الكثير من المياه والطاقه الشمسيه
لذلك نحتاج ان نركز داخليا حتى يكون لدينا
اكتفاء ذاتي عندما يتعلق الامر بالتدفئه
بيوتنا وشركاتنا
بعد تسعه اشهر على هذه الحرب على اوكرانيا
اين تتوجه وفق وجهه نظركم الى اين تذهب
الامور باعتقادكم
اكسبيريان
الحروب على الاراضي الاوروبيه بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه هذا الامر لا يؤثر فقط
على القاره الاوروبيه واذا بك ذلك يؤثر
على النظام العالمي وعلى القانون الانساني
الدولي لذلك لدينا هذا المجتمع الدولي
الذي قام بادانه الاعتداء وذلك للمساعده
نحن نؤمن في سلوفينيا بان الاوكرانيين
لديهم الحق بان يقاوم ويحارب من اجله
سلامهم الشتاء على الابواب والبيوت ستكون
بارده والكثير من الاشخاص يهربون ونحن
سنشهد موجه جديده من الاوكرانيين نحن
سنواصل المساعده لدينا ذكريات واضحه في
اذهان تتعلق بالحروب نريد مساعده المدنيين
والاطفال والنساء من خلال المساعدات
الانسانيه والماديه وكذلك اعاده بناء
البناء التحتيه والمدن ولكن هل تعتقدين
انه جرى اعطاء فرص
جيده من اجل الوصول الى حلول
ديبلوماسيه لهذه الازمه
همم
نحن لا نعرف الى اي مدى سيطول امد هذه
الحرب
ونريد ان يكون هناك مساءله لكل الجهات
المسؤوله عن هذه الفضاء التي ترتكب في
اوكرانيا نحن في سلوفينيا سنحاول ونواصل
دائما الدفع من اجل السلام والاستقرار نحن
دوله صغيره وبالنسبه لنا القانون الانساني
الدولي هو مهم ونحن سو نواصل العمل على
ذلك والقيام بذلك نحن من الذرات مكانا
يكون هناك قنوات دبلوماسيه لمناقشه الامر
لانه عندما نصل الى مرحله التفاوض انا
متاكده بان عمليه التفاوض ستتطلب من كل
اصحاب المصلحه ان يجلس الى الطاوله بما في
ذلك روسيه
تاثرت الى حد بعيد بازمه
التي نجمت عن هذه الحرب لاجئين من
اوكرانيا اليها حديثينا قليلا عن حجم هذه
الازمه الان وال المصاعد التي تواجه
سلوفينيا في التعامل معها
نحن
تاثرنا بشكل اساسي باسعار الطاقه التضخم
كما هو الشان بالنسبه لبقيه اوروبا نحن
كدوله صغيره ليس لدينا عدد كبير من
اللاجئين لكن كل من ياتينا الى اوكرانيا
هو مرحب به وسيحضى بالدعم الكامل وسنواصل
قيامنا بذلك نحن لدينا تجارب سابقا تلك
التجارب التي لها علاقه بمنطقه غرب
البلقان وبالتالي نحاول ان نتبنى مقاربه
انسانيه تجاه هؤلاء الذين يهربون من فضائح
الحرب من خلال التوفير المساعدات لهم
وسنواصل المساعده ليس فقط من خلال توفير
المساعدات الماديه لمن يحتاجون اليها ولكن
لدينا كذلك
مراكز اعاده التاهيل وهذه من الامور التي
نناقشها السلطات في اوكرانيا
لمساعده في اعاده التاهيل وكذلك من خلال
برامج مخصصه للاطفال وما شابه ذلك ما
المخاطر على هذه الازمه وعلى اللاجئين
تحديدا ان طال امد الحرب
[موسيقى]
وعندما نكون في حاله القطاع للطاقه دون ما
طاقه كهربائيه دون مياه هذا يعني ان الناس
يجبرون على مغادره بيوتهم
وبالتالي في فصول الشتاء تتدنى درجه
الحراره بشكل كبير جدا اذا ما قال اما
الاعتداء والحرب واذا ما وصلنا الى هذا
الوضع ويكون هناك القطاع للكهرباء في
اوكرانيا هذا يعني انا ستكون هناك ازمه
انسانيه وسيغادر الناس بيوتهم شكرا لكم
سلوفينيا ثانيه